hello and happy Monday everyone I'm
joined by Miguel Miguel Mondays no that
that's not a cream I just look for a
word to rhyme the good morning so today
we're playing kind of a classic but
remastered you're in a race so we'll
just get into it we are playing burnout
paradise remastered sweet and sweet jams
a little bit as you can see I'm playing
the the DeLorean a pseudo DeLorean and
you're like in a hovercraft mode you're
not even wheels down right now correct
we're playing a mission called mark man
or I believe a rival car is targeting me
and it's going to try to stop me from
reaching this checkpoint
so yes burn up paradise remastered is
now available I believe for trial yes
sorry a early access if you have EA
early access you get to play ten hours
you know early if you have that service
if you don't the game comes out March
16th so that's in a few days here for 40
bucks is it 40 I believe so that one is
a shocker to me hold on my apologies if
start to get off topic guys but no no
you're good okay
[Music]
I'm just double-checking the cost yep
$40 okay I believe wait
hmm yep it is $39.99 oh look at you you
got wrecked already hey guys yeah it's
it's about like I believe the the 10
year anniversary of the game I might be
off by a few months but I consider
Burnout Paradise to be one of the best
open-world driving games out there
though as a remaster you may not see
that many like huge differences because
the original game already looked great
as it was it has or it had already come
out on backwards compatibility on X on a
360 or on Xbox 360 yeah it originally
came out on ps3 and xbox 360 okay
this version at least I mean if if
you're hesitant about the $40 price
point I will add that it does include
all the prior DLCs as evidenced as
hinted by the fact I am driving the
DeLorean
so yeah you lost what's up RC 101 3
thinks said basically after finally
watching reruns or finally after
watching reruns of your strains from
Pope g2 into the breach I can finally
watch one live glad you can tune in live
OD pun H says yeah ten-year anniversary
was passed January 22nd thank you thank
you
what's up tech ones how are you doing
hello to a son all Zaiden how are you
doing today
let's do a race ok let's do a race show
me a race race yeah I'm ready
just so you guys know to John Luke will
probably be doing a smaller feature but
one later this week he really loves this
game it's one of his favorites and I
should also add that our illustrious
news editor Chris Pereira and I are
working on a feature on some of the best
open-world racing games that might come
out I'm writing some blurbs about this
game smugglers run to by Rockstar Forza
horizon particularly - and a few other
games I know Chris has written a few
things about driver and Carmageddon so
look out for that cartellis says I'm so
pumped for this game yeah it's coming
out soon the 16th or as we mentioned
earlier if you have EA early access you
can play for 10 hours you know on your
Xbox one so definitely get on that if
you want to test it out what's up
captain Arabia how are you hello exotic
maniac he says he or she says good
evening everyone happy to see this game
get a remaster and you love destroying
your DeLorean alright no problem don't
fit right back in it RC 101 3 he says at
GameSpot I love burnout childhood
memories and you're awesome in the
streams I remember when you try to be
late to a meeting to get to here during
the live stream survive yeah I was
definitely I was definitely late tonight
meeting and I was very disappointed that
we never got the metal gear which would
have been a perfect excuse like hey
we're summoning a metal gear of course
I'm gonna be late but instead I had to
be like we were trying to summon anyways
you get the point
what's up granted banana so one really
awesome thing about I believe it the
burnout series is assigned up in a great
video game series is it a different fans
like different installments yeah I know
there's a large contingent of burnout
fans who who actually don't like burnout
paradise as much as some other
installments even though those are
offline game
or have limited on online playability I
think like there are a lot of fans of
like three and Revenge I know of anyone
on the chat could attest to that yeah
well we'll see if chat cat chat will
catch up in a second here and then
they'll share their opinions on if you
think this is the best burnout or what
is your favorite burnout excuse me
choked a little bit there Jer Phoenix
excited for Kirby out this Friday here's
an interesting one when auntie says you
know they feel like this is kind of
underwhelming for $40 you probably
played about an hour or two yeah so far
not counting so far today so it's
probably harder for you to nestle give
me an answer but do you feel like $40 is
a little bit pricey a little I think I
mean I think it feels like it feels like
at the most $30 game you know and well
this is someone who I mean I probably
put in maybe 50 hours into the original
game okay
personally I have every motivation to
100% this one because before I had a
chance to 100% my original my original
game my original player playthrough I
had a safe corruption oh yeah I think
against No yeah it wasn't anything to do
with burnout it was actually my entire
like save data on my entire ps3 crazy
super jump look at that
what's up PSP d40 how are you doing
thanks for tuning in one other
interesting thing when I spoke to Alex
Ward the creative director of criterion
at the time he had a very interesting
anecdote telling me about
apparently Hideo Kojima his wife suda51
and his wife used to have burnt like
these late-night burnout marriages and I
forget which spouse got affected but
apparently they were playing at the time
of that famous PSN outage and one of
their save files got corrupted yeah yeah
I don't think it was him his wife or
c250 ones wife but they tried to put it
in a call to Alex almost immediately and
it was like I'm so sorry there's nothing
I could do
that's not because I am a noob when it
comes to burnout in the series is there
actual like road rage mode well there's
there are destructive modes and I think
that servic one of the reasons why this
game is so revered because despite how
many open-world games let alone
arcade-style racing games in the open
world have come out since there really
hasn't been any game that really
captures sort of like the destructive
appeal gotcha of this because someone is
basically saying everyone he watches
usually just as the races are the stunts
but no one does
destructive stuff right I guess some of
the chats favorite burnouts are coming
through RC 101 3 says regular burnout on
GameCube I don't know if he's trolling
though because he put kappa faces Nate's
9 burnout 3 is the best
we have anymore lotion I'm sorry if I
butchered your name asks when does this
release the remaster for burnout
paradise releases March 16th on Xbox one
and ps4 correct I'm pretty sure and if
you want to play it early though and you
happen to have a early access you can
play that on the Xbox one for 10 hours
before you look into purchasing so maybe
if you have your early access which I
believe is like the $5 a month I think
so roughly somewhere so like you could
obsessively just check this out for 10
hours if you want to sign up for like a
month of EA or early access for 5 bucks
master-blaster says go ro rage oh my god
and wants to crashes all right we can do
that
maybe in a little bit Master Blaster
burnout 3 for sure ia acro says I love
Paradise PSP d40 my favorite burnout
games are burnout revenge Oh deep on
says I only played this one but I can
see it being my preferred over the
others Hussein judge says burnout
revenge is this RA the remake yes we are
playing the remake we have like a copy
early so just showing this off you know
either to see if you guys might be
sparked your interest might be sparked
or just kind of reliving an old classic
yeah you know and playing this and even
like the original versions I'm reminded
how very very few arcade style
open-world racing games look like you
know they run at 60 frames per second
despite how much I love ports over rises
and you don't get that and
it's very refreshing to play something
like this that actually has like arcade
style controls even though portal risin
is sort of seen as sort of like the more
accessible version of the ports of
franchise over motorsport it definitely
doesn't have sort of like this looseness
and accessibility of the controls is
burnout paradise Chris man acts are
crisper air crisper Eric G's can't talk
today
burnout party's sounds fun Devin
Thornhill asking how are you guys doing
I'm doing good you know mondays are
always a little bit of a challenge just
getting back into the workflow they're
doing just to daylight savings okay I
did for the most part it was weird all
yesterday just because it's like the
whole time you're thinking oh it's later
than it should be I feel pretty
refreshed but also this is kind of weird
it would I kind of like um you know
springboard or day like the you know
because you get an extra hour of
sunlight which i think is great it makes
you feel like at least for me when I
leave work I'm like oh cool the sun's
still out right like you know I don't
know it's a it's a probably just a
mental thing
I wonder if let's see okay I can do road
rage work out fine road rage what the
iconic Master Blaster if you know what
it looks like please tell me so that I
can get Miguel on his way there
according to the the records I have
played a road rage yeah I agree with
most of the chat like I don't know this
is worth $40 but you know and also it
makes you wonder whether or not EA is
using this as sort of like a like we're
also a trial bed if but for other stuff
yeah it's gonna be things like dusting
the $40 price point or testing
remastered video testing the $40 price
point for remasters okay
Robert McCready Eric tase the stream
Ward I try to be not always but I try to
at least hear Oh still good Rex say so I
got I got oh I got that other car though
oh so this is is this the one
yes okay so here we go we're doing
takedowns we've not taken out
we got a deuce you're three takedowns
here I can do three takedowns and I
think yes there is something to be said
about the flimsy construction of this
DeLorean we'll try another road rage
gonna burn out to take down see yeah
everyone has different fondness for
different you know yeah their notes I'm
gonna go to garage and get something
that's slightly stirred here
it's just nick says it's finally back
winky face yeah and we should also check
out I'm gonna check out Big Sur file and
at some point that was dee-nice
okay expansion console HUD says we want
to see f-zero didn't do like a thermos
up very like it's heavily inspired of
zero game I don't know if it's out yet
but I remember seeing it at PAX a couple
like a year or two ago it the name is
eluding me but there is a game that's
heavily inspired by of zero that is
either coming out or has come out and I
just can't remember the name hmm maybe
someone in chat can help me I host my
next I'm not Chris I thought toast man X
was oh you know what it is toast man I
think I'm so used to his his name being
smoking man X and um or something like
that in our in that's true that I kind
of mix the two up so I'm sorry toast man
but I know you're always here so I
always thought you were Chris but you're
not thank you for telling me that my bad
change
Stan Edward Anthony said criterion games
should just continue making burnout it's
been best for that just when EA made a
tie-up with criterion and releasing me
for Speed Most Wanted rivals etcetera
the reputation of criterion has fallen
their opinion obviously I mean I
definitely do miss criterion as we used
to know them I'm I know much of the team
who stayed were pretty much absorbed
into ghost games that has made a number
of those get him nice the more recent me
for speeds I believe it was Need for
Speed hot pursuit that felt that felt
the most criterion s for me that should
count
oh no it is car nice car
[Music]
I was going to say now we're $40 is kind
of silly to say when you look at how
much DLC there is so all the DLCs are
free yes they come with it okay that was
a question for and resonate okay so
according to Ben
djenka he feels it's it's worth I guess
right because there's a lot of DLC so
maybe I'm wrong between all the cars
mr. beatbox is testing the viability of
the fable the Mass Effect trilogy
remastered right yeah take that other
car
master-blaster said to his records 111
that's for takedowns I'm guessing that's
pretty crazy that's that's pretty crazy
but believable we're currently just on
an Xbox one not an X
yeah we'll go to certainly what you said
Surf City right we'll go Surf City later
ooh
takedown frenzy we're on a frenzy right
now
we got keep it up yeah six in a row I'm
surprised there isn't like an NBA Jam
guy like haha he's heating up from
downtown garage
sensei says it's good to be back in
Paradise City but looked like nothing
else is upgraded about the graphics
question mark oh yeah and you win Oh cuz
you did you get rekt i already i hit my
minimum yeah yeah yeah so dang did he
get 111 in one go that's pretty crazy
PSP d40 GameSpot have you gotten the
chance to play quantum break I am not
played quantum quantum Braddock
I have played quantum break it's like a
hybrid right kind of it's like Max Payne
ish yeah a little bit of like Alan Wake
somewhere else with some time and live
manipulation ooh Randy Orton out of
nowhere RK owes us and gives us us up
what's up Randy Orton Congrats to your
your winning of the was it the you want
you want to belt last night I freak took
it from Bobby Roode that's all I know
sorry if I just spoiled that if you
didn't watch it yet but whatever I
arcade you out of nowhere then
are the EA servers available or is it
offline homeland
that's good question I mean I can check
now I do later yeah it's fine we can
check later also you can change the
playlist we do have requests from our
John Luke and I guess we'll indulge them
at some point but I'm not looking
forward to it what's up Godzilla hello
big cities this way this is also one of
the earliest games series that
introduced sort of like risky driving
rewarding for risky driving I mean I'm
getting more boost by doing risky
behavior and we're at big surf island or
going to use oh yeah mainly going the
opposite direction yeah it's a lot of
car parts oh man well welcome to Big Sur
that's a good question I'm not sure MRC
and eg says can you play with the people
who have the original non remastered
version it's a very good question guys
this game have multi player cross play
with other consoles I doubt that very
much I mean if they can't get fortnight
for ps4 and Xbox one to play yet I don't
it it keeps circling back to Sony being
Europe being the last party that doesn't
wanna or the last person that want to
join the party and there's obvious
reasons right there's obvious business
reasons of life you know there's
exclusivity of stuff I don't know I
don't see why well you wouldn't want
something like where fortnight and our
for tonight players for example couldn't
play against each other
Xbox one and ps4 but hey don't change
the song yet I love my curse as a zero
Phoenix you got it you know I mean
Microsoft's been very I mean that guests
assertive in their messaging about like
how much they do want cross-platform
okay
I don't know Remy Canadian always
lecture
I'm feeling it I'm not usually in the
middle but every now and then oh well do
you consider this medal we're just more
of just scream oh it's part it's more
scream I will go scream oh I like scream
oh sorry if I said medal and people are
gonna get it upset about medal but I
don't wanna scream oh okay I went
through my face I'm feeling I'm feeling
my age because that's that that's the
first time I've experienced a jabra like
emo music where there's a lot of
screaming right so like I figured that
in some cases you know think even kind
of thick trying to think of other bands
there's a bunch I listen to that I can
listen to more in college armor for
sleep you could have totally made up
that bad name no listen I love our
destiny there's a fun time it is metal
says it here Phoenix okay whoo oh it's a
cyborg man saying it's also scream Oh
sounds great
I wasn't wrong then that's good
[Music]
portal scout god damn Sony
all right oh so there was a question and
I don't know if you know the answer but
we'll save games from the 360 be
transferable via the cloud ooh that's a
good question
I'm guessing no but that's totally unset
since unsubstantiated guess
I will accept screamo though since I've
not actually a fan of screaming music
Killswitch Engage
though go back and forth okay it's a
metalcore says they've 1x okay thank you
didn't even know that was the thing
philanthropy has been really getting
into that emo rappers I didn't even know
you know rap was a thing what the hell
yeah I can see emo rap being a thing
what yeah who's the new band or who's a
band that I kid no relate to oh geez
oh we takin down cars get it yeah oh how
did you not get the other guy - OH
see you later good save good save
oh that's unfortunate I see what you're
going for that yes
metal as app since Devin Thornhill okay
goons illah asking at GameSpot I have
this on backwards-compatible on Xbox one
is it worth getting again how much have
you played that's the thing I mean how
much have you played how much do you do
you love the game it's so you get all
the DLC with the backwards no ok so
there's at least that - right with this
version you have another car yes I am
embarrassed to say I forgot know how to
access the garage ok chat tell me where
I can tell him to switch cars they need
additional D in this game Alma's
so different we cannot become the DK in
this game oh where are your wives I
don't have one and his is probably at
work yeah she works from home most of
the week this is here in Phoenix mm
question mark he's been rapping an emo
forever it's more like an angry angry
rapper
yeah exactly
setter you know take download need some
sort of hype man to cheer you on every
time you build up a chain of takedowns
to yawn that's why I'm saying like NBA
Jam he's heating up
boom Shakalaka that's a very good point
yeah Kid Cudi is emo rap really I did
not know that will peep Joe but Joe
buddy's email email rap what I didn't
know this was a thing I mean art I mean
if you know their lyrics brown icon on
the map okay thank you portal Scout I
mean it take if he if you like to think
about the lyrics of these familiar
rappers okay you say that there's themes
are email I don't know okay so I'm a
terrible person
I can't I don't actually listen to music
necessarily for the lyric part of it
like I you know I'll get I'll remember
the hooks and things like that you know
but I I listen more for the beat the
melody and you know sometimes you know
sometimes the lyrics on the rap but most
the time it's just how it sounds
I like you Cuddy though but like I did
not know that that would be considered
emo rafta
[Music]
Anthony Varela asked me besides TLC does
a remaster have any additional content
no not that I know of maybe some Avril -
you ask me others the chat asking me
that I've asked you okay all right John
Luke I swear to God I hope you're
watching right now if not you mister you
missed your chance here
oh I'll also field other soundtrack do
requests here but we're about to put you
but I just pressed I think you have to
do as anyone had to disable all the
warning everything else for now how many
tracks are there how many do we have -
oh there's a lot turn off all of these
ah see I mean I pressed I press accept
so it might already okay well nope no
same song can you skip songs like do you
have like a button to to like
fast-forward to the next song good
question I think maybe let me check any
good
right now that's an event now you're
still doing an event or finish the event
person they will figure it out so I
don't screw you up there press Y and
turn them all off
no then Jenkin want that Averell do you
guys think there needs to be another Def
Jam game okay sure but what's the last I
don't even is Def Jam still a thing a
Def Jam it was a fighting game right
yeah but like are they still even a
thing right now like who's part of Def
Jam that's that's newer hola Jake is
perfect if Jim
apparently lso is to chase while there's
a lot of people Alessia Cara is this is
this legit
Kanye all right let's see who could we
have fight who though Kanye q-tip pusha
t gz Jadakiss oh man Jadakiss that's
that's some old score in there for me
Big Sean I don't give up oh I don't know
I don't know man I know there's no way
they're gonna make it a fighting game
again there's no way that's more people
than I thought there would be though
so Trina says whatever song is playing
right now it kind of sounds like the
theme song from the beyblade and pain
but more Hot Shots that want to show off
their driving skills it's all about
looking for the runs knowing the spots
how cash chef versus pants fears
[Music]
press the touch pad on the bags lv2 skip
songs left bumper now maybe it's
different than this
alright why don't you just do what
better we go we got it
I regret everything oh this song okay
[Music]
I almost want to tell you this is skip
it
[Music]
what have I done
[Music]
san Edward Anthony's asking shadow
classes is my favorite game but not
including the Fumito way to anywhere
during the remake was like fair he was a
creator of a masterpiece what do you
guys junkyards defined in Paradise City
I'm not invested enough into that series
to give you a solid answer I mean the
remaster of that game by Blue Point was
very good remake the remakes are the
remake of that game by Blue Point Thank
You Miguel no problem was was gorgeous
that game I mean to me if you can get
that game into people more people's
hands I think that's awesome
great you know I streamed it like twice
on different occasions and I thought
that the remake looked pretty cool and
blue point now is apparently working on
a bigger scale remake where's a remake a
remaster I know they're working on
something else have they announced
whether they haven't announced what it
is they just said that they're working
on something else that I can't remember
if it was a remake or a master but
they're working on something bigger and
a lot of people are speculating maybe
Demon Souls which would be awesome
but I have no idea but Blue Point in
terms of their life we may agree masters
they have a good tracker could consume
not only their track record that but
this progression of having done all
these Konami games pretty darn well
and then progressing to a full-on remake
of shadow Colossus demon souls make
sense give me that I haven't I haven't
beaten anything past the first boss oh
I'd love to have a I would love to visit
that game in a in a with a fresh coat of
paint for myself at least Konami better
give Metal Gear Solid to Blue Point
again though I mean yeah I mean thinking
about that distinction between remasters
and remakes I mean I do I see that copy
of Twin Snakes in our in our lounge area
and I'm like tempted to like play that
on my break
ok so it's a it is a remake their next
game camera Tatsu also saying yeah I
heard Demon Souls
Anthony Varela says Metal Gear Rising
remake alone Demon Souls is dead it
lives on on private servers Master
Blaster the online is dead though yes I
forget was forget how many years after
skater boy did girlfriend come out
because I mean I don't know if it what
if girlfriend qualifies a sort of like
comeback single or what's your reticle I
consistently churning out hits in
between skater boy and girlfriend
funny thing is I before we even like
before anyone even asked me to play one
of her songs in this game John Lee being
the person in bed I was just thinking to
myself the other day I was like oh I
roll Avene I don't know what she's been
up to she hasn't done a song in Halo
long that I can remember now someone can
correct me if I'm wrong but she
definitely was screamo though right she
is a little mo there I'd like to think
she's doing well for herself
probably Garret Jackson says yo I can't
wait to play this game again man oh good
stick the landing
I forgot there aren't any there isn't
like any burnout or acceleration on
bikes over hundred one says but how
about that Mass Effect writer leaving
Mass Effect's to do again any bets on
how long till he Polly Richard but John
with was telling me that the that
specific writer was doing more of like
stuff for like Old Republic I think or
or things that weren't necessarily gonna
affect because like a lot of people are
like oh like what's gonna happen to
anthem and then turns out I don't even
think he was really working on like
anthem so I don't know we'll see who
knows it's not it's not a good sign
though for sure especially since the
fallout of and drama and whatever
remaster lollipop chainsaw let's let's
not get ahead of ourselves here
oh man honey why are the streets so
empty I don't know they're afraid I
think it's because the bike thing oh
okay
we've got some toy cars yeah just pick
it pick something and please switch this
on I can't stand Averell anymore she had
her time Oh what is that the Mesquite
it's boost type is aggression
this is an aggression class car PS PD
says guess why just because you listen
to music that has can mean it didn't
technically mean you're an emo oh I
didn't say that
I know I'm just saying that oh so you're
saying that Avril Lavigne is me I mean
most most of the time when they're
screaming I assume there's some emo ness
in there but maybe that's a bad
assumption maybe that's what you're
trying to tell me
badger King lol just thinking about
Admiral yesterday I searched her up and
she hasn't made a song since 2013 but
apparently she's coming back this year
who wouldn't you inner link to media
Onimusha was legit yes legit until the
third one where I fell off and couldn't
handle what's his name original yeah
professional what's his John Renault
genre no I just couldn't do it man I
just he frustrated me on so many levels
playing as I just could be I forget he
also had as much like melee combat like
I mean like weapon axes to catch you can
of sheer alright really true have role
is the new lead singer of Cannibal
Corpse are you making that ah okay what
kind of genres Cannibal Corpse metal
death metal oh that's not I don't see
anything in the wiki hold on let me okay
work Averell oh it's a searchable thing
here
now don't see anything there
oh using one of the starter cars he's in
the streets RT is because Batman cleans
the streets sure fine mr c n DG says
waiting for on rush hope it's good have
you played that one yet
no but I'm excited about it okay Nova
furious this game was so amazing I was 5
when the original game came out sadly
I'm 1516 this year and because of high
school I'm restricted right now hey man
technically shouldn't shoot me I'm not
gonna ask ya I'm just not gonna ask know
people have period I mean you know
there's in between or study period or
he's in the library or he or she's in
the library I tend to used to be great -
hey you never know man that problem game
that they teased who knows if that's a
10 shoe a new 10 shoe there was like a
line in there like the quote was like a
line of boss said like who knows because
it's definitely not a blood-borne - and
there's got to be something else that
they've been working on yeah there was a
there was this what he called the the
ninja throwing knife they're serving
this in the middle of the shot in that
teaser animation and I think one thing
that neo did prove was that you can pull
off Souls bourne-style gameplay with
like ninjas mm-hmm so that's where my
money stills is on intent you yeah we'll
see I think they I think someone from
froth from software froth from software
themselves tweeted out like oh you won't
how did you like the tees you won't hear
anything else for like the rest of the
year or maybe like end of the year or
something like maybe maybe there's a
holding out for like I don't know next
year's PSX again or maybe e3 you never
know you three is creeping up on us in
three ones here give or take so
let's see that boy wants to know hey I
love the game and I love doing glitches
I was wondering if they didn't patch the
glitches do you know that will take some
research and there weren't any glitches
though ghostbusters car unofficial the
Manhattan Spirit
Kevin Valkyr says are you excited about
Kingdom Hearts 3 I'll be excited when it
actually comes out I guess I'm so like
it's been teased for so many years now
it feels like yeah and we imagine if
like the only thing that's holding up
Kingdom Hearts is the fact that Disney
keeps buying all these studios and you
know they just feel like they need to
add like other properties you know I
mean I'm thinking they need to save the
Marvel in the Star Wars for like another
Kingdom Hearts installment we'll see
hello the last man how are you doing as
their finger says no no I repeat I
enjoyed Admirals first two albums she
was missing the love songs oh okay
Devlin says doubt it's death metal but I
was kidding about the Avril Lavigne lead
singer part okay that's what I thought I
googled that one
it's punk rock okay that's way are we
talking about this song manic Scarface
are we talking about
a virile
holy [ __ ] this guy makes me feel old
you're not trust me we're both pretty
old you'd be surprised
Asians can hide it that's all you know
before I'll be 42 this year I did look
it up that's what the power of the
Internet allows me to do master-blaster
is seconding seconding it saying it is
10 she will see I don't know there was a
couple other good like Theory crafts I
went I told I you like hit you up the
day the night off or the day after that
ax tease and I went down the rabbit hole
of Reddit and it could be so many things
and like there were so many or maybe
it's not so many but there was a good
couple theories out there and reasons
why like there's this other horror game
that like from did that I'm the name is
eluding me but it was kind of set in
that time period - and they're like what
if it's a horse war game you might have
been that one or yeah I might have been
yeah one of those two and it was just
like that could be it too I guess so I
just upgraded my license bloodborne cart
yeah I hate on the side note okay is
there anything about like how the switch
controls that makes you excited or less
excited about the remastered our souls
yeah I have to see how Dark Souls plays
in handheld mode I'm excited to play
because as mentioned before I've only
beaten blood-borne and plus the DLCs and
then Dark Souls 3 and the DLCs well
actually that's not true I didn't beat
the very very last boss there's like an
extra boss in Dark Souls 3 that I didn't
finish at the variant there's like a
dragon but I never played demon soul
well that's not true I beat the first
boss of demon souls with John Lewis on
the streams and then never touched it
after that and then I didn't play Dark
Souls or Dark Souls 2 so looking forward
definitely to trying out the Dark Souls
on switch but I am curious how that
feels
hand held like in certain games it's
fine the only thing I like know for sure
that I would tell people almost like
right away not to play like john rowe
wise is FPS
so far like in handheld mode have not
has not felt good at all mmm I almost
say take the the joy cons off and play
it that way or if you have the money to
invest into a pro controller I
definitely do pro controller
I think the pro controller is pretty
awesome I think the price of that has
gone down quite a bit too but yeah we'll
see how it plays in handheld I played
breath of the wild exclusively in or
almost 90 percent of the time in
handheld and knows fine so camera Tetsu
says I wouldn't be surprised if cage 3
Kingdom Hearts 3 got delayed again that
would be insane if it got delayed again
considering they've come out and said
that is gonna come out this year already
like that's just I don't know I don't
know how much more fans can take or
maybe it doesn't matter and maybe they
know that it's gonna be fine yeah and
also I mean even if Kingdom heart I mean
if Dark Souls remaster doesn't work I
mean if it's not my cup of tea on switch
at least it is regain remastered on the
other platforms PS PD are you asking
about Diablo games or deep Diab you
spelled di o blo Diablo games and I
don't know if that's what you mean if
it's yellow then we can have a better
comment I can have a better conversation
about that because I played all three
hello pink diamond how are you welcome
to the chat well Hampi 89 wants to know
is this game better than you for speed
you'd have to answer this one
you know at the end I can't think of any
need for speed that I would rather play
than this Hot Pursuit comes close but I
think when comparing the two the frame
rate really makes a difference and just
the arcade style controls but Hot
Pursuit has its strengths I mean there
is something to be said about just sort
of the I guess the weight of the cars
serve it in the same way people talk
about and revere the weight of like
gunplay and like Killzone games I sort
of like it quick that too sort of like
the weight of of cars in hot pursuit in
terms of like open-world games that have
both race pace goals and destruction I
can't think of anything better than
burnout paradise turning outside wants
to know Cain cussing the music still be
used that's a good question I have not
actually tested it okay
I know we're not planning any kind of
like review content to BM is that a
ghost postcard it's a knockoff coach
Joseph are jobless when I meant my auto
correction on my phone I typed your
password uh yellow I've always had fun
with it but obviously you have to I mean
enjoy that kind of like grindy blue
chase type game so if you don't then
obviously that's not gonna be game for
you I am curious if it is actually gonna
hack will come out well Hornung a gyro
gamer who has a source it's supposed to
come out on switch Diablo 3 that is if
it does come out on switch I want try it
out for sure the ps4 I play the ps4
version or the console version and that
game on console actually surprised me it
played great it played great for you
know I expected it to be pretty like
clunky but it ended up being pretty good
like and there's some systems in there
that you wouldn't get on PC like you
could trade with any of your items to
anyone which is great that I don't know
why is still not in PC but whatever but
yeah that's the world talked about
talk about some other stuff now
we'll race here listening to some
Depeche Mode pothole it I think this
this one's your favorite burnout right
it's moderate yeah yeah yours yeah so if
there was gonna be one pothole it it'd
be this one for me I haven't played very
much of the burnout stuff we're not
serious re so I can't speak to that but
uh I know John Luke I think this is
John's favorite too so we kind of did
like a mini chat poll earlier just to
see the you know different burnouts
people enjoyed the best and there was
definitely a good at a good variety
there so I think it's beauties in the
eye of the beholder
James Bond wants a remastered burnout
three take down James Bond are you on
break right now no no espionage to be
done right now that's the best is when
people have those kind of names I think
Batman's being in the chat before I was
great he must have been off duty
what's with Bruce Wayne you know go next
knee me Helio wants to know if you have
RAM phobia dude you're not going out
that many ramps I guess Jason small as
the soundtrack to intact
it looks intact I mean there sure are a
lot of songs I would have laughed if a
paradise City actually was not in the
game well why don't you scroll through
the list a little bit here so people
could see Hawk Hawk in SM 210 this is
the remastered version yes
want to see how on Rash shakes out on
Russia shakes out rather sorry I will
say it was sad when all subsequent
releases of Crazy Taxi did not have what
his offspring it because it's just like
how synonymous that band was with that
game alright so here's the soundtrack
let's get a good long list here it's a
nice reminder of just like the amount of
genres are being represented here oh
yeah and the in-house
oh yeah and like throwback music from
the previous burnouts and some classical
music no worries Jason small got your
back dude saying there's a lot classical
music on the side it just relaxes you
alright can we
I'll race these other cars in our fake
Ghostbusters car oh here you go
he's switching the tracks he's trying to
get the classical music because that's
when he'll race at his at his peak oh he
took them down okay I was like pays to
have a stronger car here
what's up Jake Paul are you doing this
yeah this is a sort of my era slash like
when I was in high school good music I
listen to a showing our age my age
[Music]
the DNG n RDR says takedown and revenge
are better than paired a city I'm oh but
PC is better than me / speed the crew of
cetera and I don't expect to take down a
reg will ever be near a third win maker
pro this is the new remaster just so you
guys know if you guys want to check this
out if you have a early access you can
play ten hours up to ten hours for free
now let's check it out if you don't then
you'll have to wait because this game
comes out March 16 don't you guys have a
flag on rocket League we do Wolfie the
beast
we have a GameSpot black
Stan Stan II Edward was it our Anthony
says are you guys Korean Chinese
Japanese
I'm also Asian by the way I'm Filipino
Miguel is Filipino and I'm Chinese I'm
I'm Michael 1/16 Irish yeah it's like I
I have probably like one something
something something oh no here they come
oh I turned a little early way to let
them back into the race yes oh come on
no it doesn't at least he crash - so you
might be fine
kind of block them maybe you should stop
changing track so you raced that's
probably what's costing you right now I
don't know if it's going to PC let me go
check for you
Oh later this year so it'll be ps4 Xbox
one and then I guess PC later this year
what I mean here we go
snacks it saved whatever happened to
that Skyrim show as Brian Valente we
stopped doing Skyrim mods a while ago
does this game have multiplayer yes
no worries Brian thanks for stopping by
that's that's kind of a big gap time gap
there if you haven't been here since
Skyrim mods oh camon severoff kind of
doing their own thing they got their own
production company now we still partner
up with them to do some some cool video
collabs every now and then so you'll see
them every now and then on GameSpot
they're with us during e3 last year but
yeah I think they still do Skyrim stuff
so if you're curious you can check them
out for PSP DS about to go listen some
Ludo rec and your car is some bad shape
there what's up bro Sam how are you
doing nobo fierce what sports you guys
like I'm a big football but Sox like in
parentheses soccer or without
parentheses but big football aka soccer
fan and I also love WWE and Formula One
I am a American football than as well as
a basketball we're both pretty big
Warriors fans guys can hate us if you
want that's fine
hey Bob I'd like to say I like to say
I've been a warriors fan since we sucked
so you know it's about time we had our
time I guess I mean I don't yeah I mean
I can't say I was a warriors fan when we
sucked though I mean that what that team
from like 2007 2008 2006 I yeah I've
gone through all that I've gone through
all the bad stuff that we believe was
when it when we started turning the
corner I mean I was paying attention to
the record when Chris Mullin was playing
with Hardaway Run TMC baby yeah favorite
WWE Superstar ooh that's tough SC Howard
I also watch WWE
I don't follow it that much I just try
to keep up to date with like what's
going on so I'll watch highlights like
the top Ted and from Smackdown top 10
from Raw on and I'll find out who who
want what during the pay-per-views and
stuff like that I mean my favorite oh I
don't know maybe Seth Rollins like even
even he'll Seth Rollins is fine I just
think he has a lot of them I like that
he has a lot of variety
in his like arsenal sorry what do you
think oh I was just gonna say that I
mean his story lines in sports is
something I really gravitate toward I
mean I'm excited to see what upsets
they're gonna be in a you know NC
double-a tournament
oh yeah March Madness right yeah about
this kick-off soon they just finished
finalizing the bracket I think yesterday
yeah and Tiger was almost won a
tournament yeah he was in the finals
right he was a final portion of it yeah
I mean he was always like you know
either one or two strokes back whoever
was leading SC Howard says good man I'm
guessing that's - uh - that's Rawlins
kind of shocked he's kind of like
falling off in terms of like not like
his ability but just in terms of like
where he's kind of ranked or rated in
the WWE he doesn't seem like he's the
main attraction well which is weird to
me what do you think that is I don't
know they just have different storylines
going on and they're pushing other
people I guess but like or maybe they
feel like they pushed him long enough I
have no idea and play well I don't get
why you guys call American football
football because you barely kick the
ball with your foot don't know man I
don't know the history of the naming
convention for it we kicked the ball
four field goals punts and kickoffs
can you explain to me why Asians root
exclusively for either the Lakers of the
wars that's actually not true that's not
sure um there's a big demographic in
like Houston who you know are big fans
of the Rockets and I feel like when the
Clippers were good their prior a lot of
clipper fans to that have now gone back
over to being Laker fans and then I
wouldn't be shocked if there was a
decent presence in New York or New
Jersey as you know Jeremy Lin when
sanity when he's in New York and then
now being on the Nets so I don't think
that's necessarily true but you know
they're probably you know Lakers have a
long-standing you know winning of
Championships and all that and the
Warriors are now like you know the
potential hopefully a new dynasty maybe
it's just more of like bandwagoning on
to the winners yeah I mean I think I
confess I was a huge bowls friend in the
90s but it wasn't yeah I guess it's it's
fair I mean there wasn't like a thing
with back then is a figure there was
just not too many teams I could compete
with the Bulls and or compete with
Michael Jordan but it was definitely fun
to watch I'm honest no a malik says do
you guys hate yay for what they have
done I don't necessarily personally hate
EA now I probably have played less games
that you know EA has published but I
could see why you know there are people
out there that aren't necessarily happy
with the a and you know when you see
those those images where you know it's
like here's the EA graveyard it's
definitely not good
yes definitely not puts things into
perspective but you know I mean they've
done their share of like publishing some
very memorable games I mean I actually
spent the holiday playing some some EA
titles that
I was very nostalgic about playing a
Bulletstorm and dead space yeah over the
holiday we are coming to the the 20th
anniversary of the square Electronic
Arts partnership we're pretty much
almost like practically every square
Safa game that came out from like 1998
mid 1998 to 2002 we thank partially to
Electronic Arts it games like eine
hunter and parasite eve oh yeah when you
see that Square Electronic Arts logo
that's because of that publishing
partnership see Max Scarface 27 says
Basilan was like an episode of SmackDown
that sucks I heard that I heard the I
heard the the main event for Smackdown
Earth's main event for Fastlane was good
though which is all you can really do or
you want good take that oh nice of
course it's better to have the hold or
most of the show be good but you know
nice oh I thought you saved it riding on
a fence
I think the e is setting up for a
program where wrong spaces Roman for the
universal title that'll be interesting I
guess Nova furious says yeah same like
Seth Rollins but I heart Finn Balor he's
a goat I think the thing is I like AI
when Finn Balor kind of moved over to
WWE I was on the finn bálor train but
then it just started to get to a point
where i don't know all the moves became
predictable and maybe it's because he
liked the demon version of Finn Balor's
the one to watch that the the main event
one because you know he pulls out more
of the stops but I just feel like so far
for me like Rollins has had just like
more moves just that he pulls out I
guess hey where were you when the
Warriors won their championship in 2015
because I know we were at e3 but I
remembered being my hotel room I can't
remember probably probably a hotel room
I remember watching the 2006 series six
thousand sixteen series where we lost it
and just being there every
watching every game in the room just
like yelling like god how are we and
then the whole dream on green getting
suspended for kicking LeBron and the
lower extremities that basically wand
them the championship I mean obviously
LeBron James and Isiah Thomas or not as
a Thomas cheese Kyrie Irving they played
very memorable Game seven but it should
have never got to that point agreed but
whatever it is what it is we won the
best consolation prize we could that
year which is lining KD so if you think
about it in that way two championships
no KD or now two championships with KD
with a hope for a third Houston looks
scary though I'm not gonna lie oh yeah
agreed
let's talk about a way out in Far Cry
five we're actually gonna put up
something from with is it Yosef yo
Senate Yosef from one of the he helped
develop the game if I'm a creative
director sorry for a way out we have a
lot to play with him that's going up
this week I forget the day might even be
tomorrow tomorrow oh is it okay tomorrow
so looking forward to that looking
forward to streaming that when it comes
out we'll have that little co-op
jailbreak park r5 you're interested we
put up some some gameplay as well as a
feature for Far Cry 5 also a chat about
it in terms of like you know our
thoughts on the game and then also John
Luke more recently this as of this
weekend did a history of Far Cry so if
you're curious on you know what's going
or like how that's all kind of come
along i watch that obviously but yeah
it'll be interesting with far cry 5 with
especially the political climate and all
that stuff so we'll see how how much it
goes into that and you know we'll play
it will stream it of course when it
comes out
toast my taxes he says he's found his
takedown group now I'm assuming you're
talking about Rollins but maybe your dog
my Bella
James Bond just started FarCry the
original on PC and says it's a hard game
I hear things about like how brutal the
the the initial one and two are you mean
back when games were actually hard no
showing my age against at your position
today do you really believe that I feel
like I don't know like hair when did the
wind at the very first part Franco came
out 2004 I don't know I guess I'm
showing my age just because I don't know
video games in the past and maybe it was
just cuz I was younger and I stuck that
game is maybe but like I feel like video
games in the past compared to now we're
a lot more difficult well then some
things I'm not saying like everything
that comes out now is in actually rawr
I'm just saying like if you look at it
from a very broad general at that point
that I feel like older games were way
less forgiving some of it also deal with
like control limitations just it sure is
but I ain't a style trick people are for
like tank controls like you know I just
think of all the games that haunted me
in like when I was young Ninja Turtles
on NES right I died so many times in
that stupid swimming level where you had
to avoid the vines while you're on a
timer and it was like the most
frustrating experience that like I can
remember as a kid I yeah
that's just that that's it
[Music]
I can get rid of that that spammer guys
no worries I see that he said the same
thing three times now
where's my hot put a user in a timeout
all right reflect on your actions of
spamming all right James Bond does agree
games were way harder back in the day I
[Music]
feel like it is kind of sobering just
firing up at a game I played growing up
and I think to myself how did I even
like to beat this I'm sure if I go back
to a lot of games that I played as a kid
that I struggled with I'd probably
perform a lot better just because I
would I'm more paid you know like I'm
more patient now I understand the
mechanics and all that stuff but still
just like on a general like man it was
very different back in the day at least
for me and certain certain games and
certain platforms like just a
Playstation one a lot of those
PlayStation 1 games are in my opinion
pretty unplayable now Stan Edward
Anthony asking are you excited about the
new God of War
based on North Norse mythology yeah it
looks it looks interesting for sure and
we'll have more to come in the coming
weeks because I'm sure will be possibly
going to to see some of that stuff so
stay tuned obviously will definitely
scream it when it comes out but yeah
it's it's coming on in April right so
like a month away which is which is
crazy to think about or 20 or 20 but
yeah there there's been some pretty
solid game so I'll come out this year
right now I feel like we're in a little
bit more of a little bit of a dry period
right before you know some of these
other bigger games are coming out end of
March you know you have far cry 5 you
have sia thieves you have some other fun
titles like attack on Titan ninokuni -
yes which am I allowed to save his
review no Kuni - I'll just say that
we're reviewing ninokuni - and
so stay tuned for that kind of think
what else we we have on the Kirby app is
Ella did allied all-stars they're gonna
say that right that that game comes out
this Friday as well and that'll get a
review to Detective Pikachu's gonna get
a review so sideswipes you know one
thing that does excite me about God wars
now that they've moved on to another
group of gods that basically opens the
door for other mythologies not just
Norse I'm so Annette had had mentioned
Battletoads is being really hard yep
that is another real hard game any news
on black ops for not nothing new as of
like you know what they tease and I
think they did the release date to right
I believe if I remember correctly it's
such a frustrating unorthodox Roman
numeral wow this guy just has multiple
names just before eyes up why are we why
are we why are we what's wrong with what
Nova said I think there's fine let's see
I need to get rid of this guy that came
back as someone else though this guy is
persistent ago someone wanted you to
Wake Island there you go
it's this guy come on wait why is there
a Wake Island am i making that extra
balance I think oh yeah we already went
there sorry I'm like trying to do two
things at once and you're me being a guy
I'm terrible at multitasking
who's hype for GTA 6 come on Master
Blaster we gotta get Red Dead to first
which already got like a delay yeah I
need to beat the first ride then
I am kind of curious what they're gonna
do with black ops though because like
black ops 3 was the one where they
introduced like you have like heroes
right like I'm hero abilities hmm so I
don't know are they going to continue
with that or making a multiplayer dial
back yeah multiplayer sorry because like
you know you like each character had
different abilities I think you can pick
from two right
like I remember Reaper if I if I haven't
gained that right was the robot and I
remember I got I used the clone a lot
because it was so dirty you just send up
three or four clones from your body and
people would shoot the clone that then
kill them and they're like the media
says I really hope got a war just blows
people away yeah hope so I mean it's
been a while since we've gotten a got a
war game
a rabbit 94 J says you think it's worth
it to buy a 4k and ps4 Pro for Red Dead
Redemption - maybe you want to
experience that game with the at the
highest one of the highest well actually
technically Xbox one X would have higher
fidelity huh this new consoles probably
yeah yeah because the PC version will
obviously come out later as you know
almost all rockstar games go they come
out in console first and then they'll
release PC later on so Wake Island is
from battlefield sick
thanks bad
any idea when 49 state of the world will
be available to free that I'm not sure
because yeah right now only the Battle
Royale is free which I would assume most
people are playing compared to the save
the world mode is this version of
burnout any different from the older
version you know honestly it's pretty
darn identical but it also speaks to
just like how smooth and slick the
original game was are you guys any good
at stunt races I'm truly terrible I'm
not doing well today but I always found
that it was easier to do stunts in the
hills as opposed to the streets but
that's also because my video graphic
memory of where the six sick jokes are
as well hey man there's a jump here we
can he news on cyberpunk no I mean I
guess if you want to go down that rabbit
hole of all they got Twitter verified
and they did like what was the tweet
they put out like beep or something he
was some Perry just like whatever tweet
I think I got it oh I think I got no I
love the combo I would say maybe hold
out hope for you three when I'm on who
knows any news on dishonored three not
that I know if I like how they're just
trying to fish and hope that I have
actual information I got nothing for you
guys man yeah
black ops worth coming out on the Friday
on a Friday
[Music]
does this version come with all the DLC
cars already unlocked yes
Pedro shavon shavon search I believe it
does
did you survive that no guess the
driving away oh you're a hit-and-run er
huh
gucchi Iowa I just want a full trailer
for shadow guys twice this year I mean
know what game that is so that's the
that's the firm software game that's the
unofficial title is that's the only like
words that they use in the teaser oh
that was for the front software right
yeah that's right I can't remember all
these things will there be a half-life 3
yeah probably not let's be real here
come on prints Rosario's back and this
time doing a better job of not spamming
in all capitals see how long that lasts
welcome back Wow Bob Joe is going with a
bold prediction I say cyberpunk 2077 or
2077 is coming out this fall and we'll
learn that at e3 that is a bold
prediction I think it'll be already
pretty amazing if we hear about it and
get like some type of gameplay in for
cyberpunk
and that would already be a lot this
week yeah we haven't seen any gameplay
yet right no we've only ever seen that
one trailer like from a long time ago
that was like pretty cool but like what
is that really it showed nothing of the
game other than like you know like maybe
time period then like what the game is
gonna kind of be about or you know what
I mean here we go
[Music]
mr. Steve Cady I don't know when this
will be released on PC I saw it was just
supposed to be later this year Vince was
are you saying sorry it's all right for
now well sure
how did I not crash okay apparently if
he hits I see
okay trying that someone's giving us a
tip MIT Romney says his hit the bumpers
on the controller at the same time
you'll start to roll and then you just
take out everything in your way to keep
the buspar up so you can keep tumbling
towards traffic I guess oh right okay I
got it nice thanks right
mitt Ram me like Mitt Romney but not
look at this we were dancing
what's bl3 was that an acronym
Borderlands 3 I think that's what Goku
TV's universe I hope we get something B
I would assume that's Borderlands 3 news
at GDC or e3 interesting I don't know
what was the last is it a game that
tanked it was the like MOBA shooter
what is it battleborn battleborn yeah is
that gonna be like their last chance to
come back we think Borderlands 3 maybe
in gearbox
yeah well to see oh look at this that's
awesome thank you for the tip tomato
Chris I'm still playing the division
after all this time she were looking
forward to e3 for the reveal division -
yeah I'm actually excited to see what
that's like - because I feel like if
there was ever if there was well there
was a time before but if there was ever
a time to overtake destiny - and just be
like that online shooter you know that
you know people play on a weekly daily
basis it's probably gonna be in the
division - and it'd be pretty cool if it
came out this year I have no idea if
it's coming out this year if they're
just revealing it they've done such
great work with division
coming out with like updates and
refining their game sort of in the same
vein that destiny one did where they
they kept refining the game so got to a
really optimal spot so as long as the
division to make sure to keep its
features from division that they've that
they've already put in the game Division
two is gonna be better than destiny to
probably this also you know coming from
the same publishers like rainbows but
yeah we'll have to see though because
obviously we won't know till later in a
couple months but it's gonna be a cool
time and maybe I should probably jump
back into Division one like Michael
Hardy was we also put out a piece on
what we want in the division two if you
haven't checked that out you should it's
pretty cold little chat and you are
killing it now with the point thanks
mitt I was a good one
good that vice rather your car is
getting destroyed I love it though take
down the cars that go around and free
roam to unlock them it's what OD
Poncho's alright you want to do like one
more little thingy yeah what's a holiday
one more race hot burnout paradise we
messed returning that for that remember
you guys if you have EA early access you
can get out there and play this game now
on Xbox one yeah ten hour trial
otherwise if you're looking forward to
this game is $39.99 on ps4 and Xbox and
eventually PC at some point so the
Division two is confirmed yeah it's a t
why they confirmed it last week I think
was it Friday or Thursday
I can't remember my I'm losing track of
time but I think it was Thursday or
Friday they pretty much confirmed it and
that we would see more of it and
whatever capacity that means at e3 so
I wish they would bring back the Rainbow
Six Vegas series who knows
Hugh gear says the best place where this
mode is in the middle of cross street
agreed Valerio also saying I wouldn't be
surprised about a ps5 to be honest yeah
who knows I mean there was like swirling
rumors about that to write this even
with GDC I mean connected to GDC which
is happening next week yeah I'll see
it's not it's unheard of for a console
to be actually unveiled at GDC if any
historians remember it was also where
the original Xbox was failed because
video game says that was impressive and
then some master blasters had too bad no
explosion Linux 177 hello all right
what's this last you're doing mark man
all right I just got some live okay
survive and good luck thanks we go out
on a double you hear
drive in parallel with this guy's is
there any way that des need to is saved
by the end of this year ass rabbit 94 J
it's possible um
what they can do is what they did with
come on I'll give you one more shot at
it no it's fine I mean you get to keep
going yeah okay the only way I could see
them potentially getting saved is it if
they come out with a big enough DLC or
expansion like they did with taking king
where the it introduces like a bunch of
new stuff like we'd need to see probably
like a new class potentially or like new
sub class at least and then we'd also
need like you know just like another
planet or like another enemy type
because it's kind of getting a little
old with the ones that they have so I
mean a lot of it depends on the some of
those things I just said obviously
there's other things that could help you
know potentially save it but those are
the things that come to mind off the top
of my head well right now is the time
for the division to strike and they had
a chance a real good chance when it
first came out to kind of compete with
destiny and then it kind of just fell
off a bit because of the exploit stuff
with you know the incursions as well as
the debt the dark zone that kind of put
a sour taste and some people's now a lot
of that stuff has now been fixed they've
added a lot of cool new you like modes
and things like that
and event-based things so yeah just
someone asked about watchdogs 3 you
think we're gonna get a watchdog 3 hard
to say I don't know do you think 4 9 on
mobile will work as pretty Bruno I want
to see it I don't be interesting I don't
know how that's gonna play out just on
mobile alone without trying to add on
like a control or something there are
controller peripherals for from mobile
but at that point why why would you play
on mobile but it is interesting to see
that they beat pub G to the punch there
because pub G is
you know had had a mobile game in the
works probably still does and they got
their they're gonna have cross
I like how you playing classical music
they have they're gonna have cross play
across PC Xbox and mobile iOS so you
know we'll see how that goes
interested in maybe if it's we could try
streaming it on mobile it'll be a hell
of an experience at this they probably
won't look very good if we ever screamed
on mobile very rarely but we have the
dongle to make that a thing so you know
barely made who knows we could try it'll
uh it'll be interesting that's for sure
all right cool um any last thoughts
Miguel no let me this this could be one
of the many games that I look forward to
just playing when I'm not in the mood of
playing a work-related game it's nice to
see this uh you know property introduced
to maybe folks who actually never don't
even remember burnout paradise the price
point I guess is what I would is a
little high but it's nice that you don't
have to worry about getting any more DLC
yeah so the price point if you guys were
curious and didn't know and haven't been
watching stream is 39.99 it does come
out March 16th which is I believe Friday
this week however as mentioned earlier
if you have EA early access you can play
ten hours for free on Xbox one so you
know obviously do that if you want to
otherwise yeah thank you guys so much
for tuning in we'll be back tomorrow
same time 11:00 a.m. we're gonna be
checking out Assassin's Creed origins
newest DLC a Pharaoh's curse and yeah
should be should be fun time and then
Wednesday I believe unless I decide to
last-minute switch something we'll
probably try to check out some Devil May
Cry HD collection that's out this week
as well comes out tomorrow and yeah look
forward to the rest of the week at 11:00
thank guys all for tuning in appreciate
it Thank You Miguel for playing no
problem then we'll see you guys next
time
thank you guys it's like guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]